right now it's time to explode some
World War two testicles Alex with Sniper
Elite 3 not actually called sniper
release version 3 it's called III in
Europe oh it is yeah yeah North America
can tell it was sniper elite v2 now not
so much as you can see here alex is
already not sniping so know how much of
this game because you played a bunch of
this both you guys have actually done
yeah Alex first of all the do how much
of this game is this close-quarter is
kind of stealthy stuff as much as you
want really I do a lot of sniping I did
a lot of something when i was playing
this yesterday and but i mean you can
sneak through and knife everyone if you
want some people you have to snipe or
shoot but there is quite a bit of it if
you choose to play that route so have
you been picking the sniping because you
just prefer the sniping or is the stud
stuff not good um the stealth the self
stuff like that night running up and I
think someone is okay it's the same
animation every time but I'm gonna kill
this guy rope go get I'm Kenneth what
work call your organs I'm saying along
I'm saying stomach I'm gonna go oh that
was a liver I think that was a little
shocked yeah yeah and you also know and
now his head is burning over all right
nicely done let's get that guy ah so
yeah sniper Lee obviously known for
these kind of a slow motion bullet or
yes internal organ destroying shots I
the one we of course we're enforcing
earlier you can blow off Minsk us
together oh my god or like fragments
skull yeah first v2 was really good but
they they definitely seem to be leaving
more into it this year but with lucky
with like the organs because it was just
bones before predominantly anyway wasn't
it well the bones will shatter and like
fragments there's a model for that
oregon's sometimes will like burst or
something like that but mostly it's just
blood like they don't deform too much in
the way that bones do so even though it
is tempting to make every shot a nut
shot yeah it you also want to go for
bones sometimes because they shatter in
gross weight I always go for both yeah
so um why I'm staying right here is
because as a generator
behind me that's making noise and
masking my shots aah every so often so
I'm going to hang out up here for a bit
and jo chilman pick up pick up crossing
over there can you snap a man's get him
when he's sitting down oh no too early
oh yeah oh yeah I got it you think it's
gonna be what what the hell did you um
look at it you did it real good boys so
sometimes you can snipe like grenades if
they're on the belt of the guys all very
much so that could have happened that's
cool uh there could have been I think
there could have been some kind of tank
of fuel in there but you know this is
interesting I want to all the folks at
all know as well if you've got any
questions in the twitch chat or in the
gamespot comment so JS Bach shot I feel
free to throw them in there just stick a
big old question in capital beforehand
right and the guys will get them add to
us here on the on the on the stage all
right what are you doing here you got
some tutorial stuff cuz we're learning
about this sort of stealth mechanic
right like yes on screen right now you
have this little eyeball that shows your
visibility but once you're like once
they hear a noise it goes into this
whole other tiered system of like
stealth discoverability that guy oh he
jumped over the nut particular go AWOL
oh oh wow incapacitate that's horrible
if you like like is he gonna be a wheel
chair there so what ya like you
basically shattered his pelvis oh but
you can actually if you look like keep
an eye on him yeah he can be revived so
you can do that like super nasty sniper
thing of like incapacitated dude to draw
out other guys and then snipe them I
forgot horrible movie that was so saving
private ryan was a was it and that's how
I Vin Diesel got cat oh ok me his first
ever moving really yeah Spielberg saw
his pilot anyway you've not destroyed
one testicle yet I haven't I'm working
on it Danny you dig up your testicle you
let me see if any of this guy I can't go
sleep unless I see some testicles
exploding see you better oh yeah that'd
incapacitate you all right yeah well not
then so now you've got this extra
glowing meter on the right side of sort
of the bottom right side of the radar
circle yeah
and it'll basically cool down as people
search for you and as you get away from
site and so outs we were talking earlier
and you know you were mentioning you can
do it you know you can go full stealth
you can actually kind of just like crazy
snipe your way through and if anyone
gets close to try to you know silenced
pistol them or SMG them what has been
your preferred play style so far sort of
what have you found yourself gravitating
towards I really like sneaking up behind
them and shooting them in the head with
the silenced pistol oh nice find that
the most satisfying like if I can do it
right here like that oh just such a such
a satisfied king and its course um I
also not the biggest fan of the gore no
yeah yeah so I tend to stick to more
towards the sound suppose colleges think
it's a bit too much might be a little
bit yeah yeah hey Chris I got a question
here from the chat yellow Sanchez says
can you obtain a domino effect kill
streak from one shot you seen ah weird
like the bullet goes yeah yeah will do I
was trying to do that in the now playing
that Sean and I did I was not able to
but I i remember being able to do that
in v2 I know I did it too man with three
people are Alex three yeah 3 yeah they
did you get three nutshots cuz if you
don't do that now it's like a minute see
you're fired bro you got it you got ah
don't you either watch he's presenting
do it now notice what he's incapacitated
someone's gonna come and help them up it
doesn't get you gotta go you gotta at
least finish line up like no go ahead
wait for someone to come and then shoot
them and you know a big oh that's it
that's it he's come do you know how big
German testicles are like I've seen a
lot have you yeah just by watching like
the world cup sheriff I'm echoes I got
done yeah he died isolated ghost yeah
well I mean that he was alone and I did
without Navy's a ghost is he haunting
you yes yeah well she's testicles off
with his testicles haunt you for the
rest of the game for every ghost
experience bonus you get you uh you get
another ghost following you and haunting
your turtles
and van t asks can you turn on slo-mo
for all shots you seen it like that Alex
you can turn it on for any kill shot
with a sniper rifle okay anything else
it just doesn't get blood yeah you're
not going to get SMG or silenced pistol
stuff uh but yeah you can't you can't
adjust how frequently it happens okay
you can like choose increased or normal
or like no x-ray well there's a few more
options try to give this go be free here
we go here we go keep your job at
gamespot no like no it's not wanting me
to get that nut I believe in you we are
gonna have to get have a lesson on
German male anatomy apparently why are
you doing that when you set this leap
sleeping guy in that tent oh yeah then
you said oh he might be dead yeah you
didn't kill him a natural causes dead
yeah a lot a lot of people in the North
African Wars Rommel just waited and they
just died of natural causes yeah at
noodle legs on twitch asks how is the
length of the game does the slow mo
bullet stuff get annoying torretta Alex
you played upon you played like good 5-6
hours of this right just not wanting me
to uh oh here we go I don't know is he
gonna get lucky with the crushed nope
wait oh so close oh oh well I'm a bit
more zoom if you all push up on the
d-pad get nice get that nice bullsh um
well anyways as what's his name was
asking yes um itch it is the same sort
of Bullock am every single time you do
it so I did find that it did get they
try get old after a while so you can
just press a and skip it okay if you
want to to pick up the pace with it at
that stage is the game still fun like
what just like what do you think about
this have you enjoyed playing it like
isn't something that's worth picking up
um if you're really into stealth games
like this I think that it's pretty good
it's I i mean the the AI isn't the best
ever they stay on you know strict paths
and yeah they just go straight back to
doing their own thing even if they find
a body really yeah okay nothing's really
changed if you just wait it out for a
bit yeah they kind of do like they get
that those alert that there's a yellow
circle on there so they'll be alerted
and they'll kind of
search the nearby area but yeah yeah I
mean they're not too tenacious right
though there or what there are different
difficulty sliders do you know that
affects their kind of awareness yeah it
does it does affect their awareness I
think the alert timer last longer they
are more aware of things going on around
there is there anyone left in this map
to murder I'm working hard here's like
dozens yeah all right well time is not
your friend of the moment waste were to
get small oh I think if you wait for
this issue crazy crazy thinks he can do
84 to get a lot little smaller aim small
miss small right I don't know what I
just got under another pressure right
there's a guy right up on that Ridge
through that Bush sir yeah well he's not
gonna be our intern anymore if unless he
gets three nutshots and like I'm by
three nutshots I mean I want six bald
here sick you never is up no you never
stubble ok at least I have never seen
that I don't know okay so three bowls oh
it's may have seen something that could
be bowls I don't want an extra ball I'd
be happy with with like a set then I
guess I wasn't a nice headshot where do
you think German people's testicles are
Alex in their heads apparently somewhere
in the head region Elvis let's try to
get somewhere we go I believe in you
while you're doing Nash more questions
as soon asked about the multiplayer if
you guys played any of it negative I
couldn't get into any games besides one
wanna be one okay today um I mean it's
basically the same as single player
except you have another guy stalking you
I think the game is out today yeah yes
so it's not we haven't had too much
experience right with there is co-op in
this as well I still unsure if I sell in
the menu I thought I saw cooperative huh
I haven't checked that out it'd be good
to cover my six with a trap it would
cover your sex but a trap full of German
testicles barrel looks dangerous
yes observations about my environment
for boy faculty huh has the voice acting
in this game Alex not really a fan yeah
you know you could have stuck that knife
and it's testicle yeah all right here we
go all right let's go make-up free
before me that's here got a good sniper
perch here mmm take your time okay just
really line it up wait until like your
breath isn't totally emceeing right it
just Zen the tiniest red spot no too
high too high you can zoom in a bit more
if they lower nope I don't do it okay
alright alright see it wait for you shot
wait free shot there's an art to taking
a man's I'm gonna go for wigan bear is
it you think look Juliette I think that
was oh oh he's not gonna bro bro
goodness that was such a close call you
all set his testicles were you know k
yeah the biscuit almost went into the
basket that's good hosted man I'm just
not having luck today oh gosh whoo-hoo
should we know yet he sees your ghost
995 is I if I saw a ghost of a dude he
was taking peoples balls all right well
be there in a tight spot this could be
interesting you're right spot you're
free ballin yeah looks like oh my god
yep that is elite right there yes yeah
skill or don't if we went to restart
this area would you have a couple more
shots from that perch yes do that do
that do that okay do that I've swear to
God maybe this says all i all i care
about this video game but all i care
about is to see in some someone get the
eye here we go Danny I think regular
viewers of the lobby know where your
priorities lie oh please God take his
body like that's intestine else would
you exploit he had to dhryn aids for
balls that could be the only explanation
as balls are definitely gone man we can
say that hey hard no bone I think you
can get one more I think he can do it
you want to restart it ah try for me
whatever you need to do yeah you can
reset your image you need all right that
was perfect perfect spot let's try to
get it Milo is very quickly I will say
the reloading time on this doesn't
you want to play it more because it
means you can just keep harvesting balls
right it does do a new house just load
very quickly so far away lower not
getting that guy used to irrigate yeah I
tried I try not to it if this was the
forest you Jackie be really hard to
shoot their balls off don't even know
they don't even have them any on Ken
dolls that might be Alma that might be
good deals crouch uh-huh you are getting
all sorts of crisis right oh shoot right
up to waste everyone man i'm i'm not i'm
not i don't want to go on to the next
section of the show until you get a bowl
yeah get what i get your voices in my
ear about no oh my god I gotta yeah not
happening reload reload you still hear
something one more shot okay we're gonna
do this maybe there's someone closer
than that guy is there something love a
guy right no closely you just gotta
think before yourself in the mindset
things that dude right there right there
look at him look where's Lee right he's
just asking personals get taking a look
you can can you shoot Eve where his butt
is in those not very form-fitting lower
where are you aiming I don't want to
they're like right up it ok you ready
guys get those bull on kidney styles
here we go here we go come on no scope
baby no scope awesome it's not great and
he's looking through a scope yeah loaded
again oh yeah again load it again all
right the twitch chat is spoken they
want their balls oh I load it into
couple high alert always on the run
motion in motion bullsháá this is the
shot you were born to take man it's
really not wanting me to get the balls
oh we might have one on come on come on
I was pretty low please don't explode oh
no you did get a glimpse of him I got
the season going with you got a glimpse
is that enough to say she ate your ball
loss no it ain't the ball my ball lost
is just even more ravenous now that I've
seen said you've got a taste and you
want more oh this is getting
yes reload reload it tested shot what
did tested it out I'm voting into a high
alert situation now it's fine get that
guy yea he's an idiot all right cigar
learn no he's skeezy behind the ball
protector who that's gonna get us some
long I'm hoping his balls at talks
ostrich of his over his pants oh oh my
god out the ribs I don't know if we're
gonna get it is one more child okay one
more this is the Eric this is the world
cup final of taking dudes balls do it I
believe in you is your shot us second
honorably the way Ron all right wait for
it let the holes come to you look
there's guy to the right of the tent
he's fairly stationary let the dolls
come to you this is gonna be tough he's
in a crouched position there's a lot of
stuff down near as balls come on do it
homie the tested oh wow whether he
didn't have any books I was not a tenant
he did not evolve a listen hey look I
didn't know so many of you there's a
there's a plurality of human physiology
is this the eunuch brigade be that guy
shoot that guy yeah ah the pressure but
nobody much Chris you've got one shot
Griffin one shot load this is sniper
elite version free it's out on a bunch
of platforms ps3 ps4 xbox 360 what is
this kind of funny I can't and windows
wait inverted yes we're playing this on
it what's the button again as it rrb to
do the slow down um yeah our beard plus
any lipstick is a very challenging
okay he's got someone sneaking up behind
you too I don't care who end up you fool
I do it and oh they got that guy in the
back red oh you're getting murdered from
behind I am he's taking your balls like
goodness oh oh I'm sorry guys well
that's you know you win some you lose
yeah Thunder love you lost this one nuts
i nuts nut shots zero fired fired yeah
yeah you had a good run buddy i'm just
gonna be taking this right here I'll be
honest II day it might be a slow week
next week might we might have you back
on to try and get even more nut shots I
I'll try my best Alex nice thank you so
much for coming on thank you guys don't
know some German balls even if they
didn't get it
you